plus d'offres les couvertures de
magazines de charme hier sur ce compte
instagram florence foresti a poussé un
coup de gueule contre les affiches
pornographiques qu'on peut voir sur
lecture ce que par médian elle a déclaré
est-ce qu'on est obligé de se taper ça
tous les jours sur nos kiosques pour
mémoire les enfants ont des yeux et un
cerveau donc la salle a dérangé alors il
ya eu une réponse de hot vidéo voilà qui
est un des magazines et plus affichées
ils se défendent en disant que les
magazines x sont affichés de cette façon
depuis des dizaines d'années nous
entendons son désir de censure d'une
affiche ou une actrice est en string
avec une autre avec une autre topless
avec de floutage pour ne quasiment rien
laisse apparaître rappelons que les
magazines hic son tacticien ainsi depuis
plus de 30 ans ce qui fait relativement
long pour sont offusqués ne mêle
adroitement de chris cao jours alors le
magazine sont des prix aussi directement
à florence foresti madame foresti est
elle tout aussi gêné lorsqu'elle voit un
homme nu en maillot de bain à la une
d'un magazine féminin publie sa moitié
et dévoilée
voilà donc c'est pareil parce que moi je
suis d'accord avec florence foresti
d'après j'ai pas de revenir à une
société puis du monde et puritaine où il
est pour le coup un mois je trouve
qu'elle a raison je trouve qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans une société de plus en
plus pornographiques et aux côtés de
jean michel et qu'il faut faire
attention ce compte on va acheter les
des stickers panini homes aux pokémon et
on voit des enfants effectivement ils
peuvent poser des questions et je pense
qu'elle est aujourd'hui cette prise de
fonction en tant que mère de famille ce
comité est on prêt à diriger des tours
j'ai apposé dans ce magazine
non c'est vrai que j'ai fait d une photo
avec plein d'acteurs non j'étais pas
venu mais ne pas dire non ah ben tiens
tu peux rien j'ai un enfant mais c'est
vrai que j'ai avec mon petit chez moi
j'ai posé pour hot docs vidéo
[Rires]
quand on demande au cas où est ce que ça
ne rime en quoi jeter sur
l'investissement et est inquiète
magazine hot vidéo et qui est vrai aussi
que c'est plus facile de contrôler une
photo comme ça que tout ce que les
gamins regardent dans leurs portes à
s'exprimer dans la lah pour n'a jamais
été traumatisé de voir ça depuis qu'on
est petits fins et des fleurons alors
pour rester d'humoristes la sweden non
non la fleuriste c'est sûr que c'est la
pollution visuelle pour nos enfants on
est dans une société allait les enfants
vous non pas encore mais peu vis-à-vis
des enfants de 7 8 ans qui voit les
femmes à poil devant excusez moi dans
une société où la pornographie est
totalement décomplexée des jarres en
télévision sur internet maintenant mary
c'était le seul endroit un peu neutre et
d'ailleurs non les informations ce n'est
pas du ressort des coeurs ce qui est la
fiche d des couvertures bd régie
publicitaire merci oui monsieur
oui merci
qu'ils épargnent ça met une pression du
coup tout le monde se retourne c'est un
truc un soutien non merci
non mais ce que tout cammas c'est
horrible ce que tu m'as c'est
hallucinant c'est que dans les films on
en voit mais à n'importe quelle heure à
21 heures du porno on en voit partout et
l'est s'offusque laurent je les aime
bien mais d'une simple image owen fille
n'est impossible mais c'est pas la
pornographie sageri ça ce n'est pas fini
puisque et d'options à tout puisque
d'internet pour tenir jusqu'à l'été une
classe à la télé photo puisque le fait
qu'ils aient plus de cannes à blanc la
télé ça tu peux mais pas ça mais j'ai vu
la photo de gauche lala com sa levée un
peu celle là était violente c'est juste
la hanche qui l'avait sais pas ce que je
faisais de radio 1
on peut évidemment sont offusqués je
comprends très bien mais mais la nature
est heureusement bien fait des enfants
qui ne comprennent pas ils ne
comprennent pas ce qu'est compagne 6
inscrits sont déjà ils ont déjà vu
ailleurs
et voilà ils sont bien pu choquer quand
ils voient des craintes émises ont fait
est que sa fille arrêtée elle était
choquée pour la couverture
d'entreprendre kce